pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier
[Musique]
g
c'est toujours dire que ça revient petit
bonjour soit innovant jeu serafino pour
le moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à part
[Musique]
si la pièce est ce qu'ils vont trier
comme ça enfin bon
c'est pouya photo répondre tu m'avais
dit laissez là que sur la peur pour ne
pas déranger puisqu'il paraît que tu es
malade
j'aime demande bien pourquoi tu inventes
encore cette maladie à quoi ça sert
d'être malade ça me donne une excuse
pour ne pas voir si tu sais qu il ça me
permet de faire les courses parce qu'il
se fait peur et que tu sais aussi jouer
en scène je suis rom et un volet savoir
quand j'en passe par où tu veux que je
me marie ecay vous alvino alors que tu
sais parfaitement que je ne l'aiment pas
et que j'aime adriano voilà pourquoi je
suis malade parce que j'ai une mère
comme toi je en train de pleurnicher
suffisamment dans fait qu'à sa tête il
m'oblige à me marier à la fois que ta
mère un jeu puis vers les mains de
reconnaissance je pense que j'aurai
épouse et albino parce que tu auras
épouser un homme bon jeu de perdre pour
autant avec un appel à diana n'est pas
un homme non c'est un conte est un conte
cameri du parc encore et pour une fille
comme toi a compté par un homme en tout
cas pendant ma rue puisqu'il est déjà
mariées mais justement il peut très bien
se rendre libre assume un jeune
originaire il dit toujours ça une fois
les hommes mariés qu'ils en parlent plus
là prête et puis si nous sommes pas en
france
chez nous le mariage c'est du solide à
solide et c'est pour ça j'ai douze
albino pas à faire du solide à
l'instituteur oui c'est du solide
je te fais pas épouser n'importe qui et
puis avec qui je sais que nous aurons
toujours toi vivre maintenant fixer une
retraite
dis moi tu m'as dit pas s'il a paru dans
la revue fora tard mais n'ont rien non
il n'était pas dans une porte cochère en
train de regarder mais ce n'est pas ce
qui hier il est resté là plus d'une
heure
c'est lui qui me l'a dit au téléphone
audio heureusement je n'étais pas sorti
à ce moment là si ce n est autre qu ils
se frayent des cadeaux avant et on n'a
jamais fait un
c'est un radin ton temps tu penses
jamais qu'à l'argent et aux cadeaux
parce que c'est ça à la mort ils
m'envoient des fleurs celle de ce matin
était superbe voix les fleurs ça ne dure
pas vu les siennes à cause d' alvin on
doit les revendre en ferait que du coin
des cases arrive c'est toujours ça de
gagné on a tu penses trois jours sans
voix il en veut plus
il est resté plus d'une heure à regarder
mes fenêtres mais ce n'est collège julie
fonceur avait justement il même comme un
collégien tas c'est peut-être pour ça
que se lève d'ailleurs probable sinon tu
je ne va falloir parce qu'il pourrait
emballer les blonds oui le blond wimille
à quelque chose d'indéfinissable qui
vient de l'éducation sera aussi beau
l'éducation ça me plaît ça va bien de
dire ça au fond du lait moeurs qui les
confronte heureusement tu n'aurais
jamais regarder ben c'est un ensemble
qu'on aime chez quelqu'un ce n'était pas
content il sera différent en sacrifiant
qui l'aurait pas les mêmes mains par
exemple qui verrait alors qu'il est
bloqué ce que je paierais pour l'instant
ça qu'une chose je l'aimais mêmes et si
tu continues en opt à m'arrêter jean
batou par dessus bord doit albino et mon
mariage
on en est là c'est la fin non seulement
tu me met dans une situation impossible
tu brises ma vie au départ pour un
rigolo je risque ma vie au départ et en
plus tu fais exprès de me casser les
pieds alors quoi que toi je te vois dans
les plumes compris
[Musique]
bon eh bien parlons d'albinos qui le
font via des tuyaux qu'elle fuit au val
tuyaux des renseignements sur sa fortune
est pas encore tout à fait mais c'est
pas vrai non mais ça fait plus d'un mois
que ça dure cette histoire jamais moyen
de savoir au juste ce qui est à moi je
te préviens ma robe de mariée commander
mais si je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
possèdent tonton albino l'envoie là
pouvaient nous sommes à la poubelle en
robe de mariée mais tu vois ça me fait
de la peine parce que c'est encore la
seule chose qui me plaisent dans
marianne au penser que les sortir de
l'église avec ma robe blanche et ma
couronne laurence dané minutes
n'oublions pas que sortie de l'église à
part c'est pour toi que je me marie pas
pour moi non plus t'entendre gmi et
ressasser qu'on finira la ville était
vieux jours tu mourras 3
alors affaire à faire je vais du beurre
dans les épinards d'accord mais je veux
savoir s'il ya du beurre ne serait ce
que par amour propre d'ailleurs dans mes
coups de poing un peu la peine de
regarder tu as fini il peut mettre assis
sur sa note albi non c'est encore lui
qui va faire la belle affaire ben fait
rouler comme dans un lit ça au plus cher
que sa valeur trop peu plus ça c'est que
tu lui demandes toi même quand il va
venir je dis donc pas d'acquis albinos
qui représente sa fortune tu veux aussi
je discute le contrat d'oubli le rôle
que tu me fais jouer je joue un rôle moi
je suis une jeune fille amoureuse
ingénue j'épouse enfin le professeur de
mes rêves que je rencontrais tous les
jours dans l'escalier puis six mois vont
être une voie non non tu vois dans ce
qu'on allait lui dur de but en blanc
digne de albinos est pas tout ça mais ce
mariage ça va nous rapporter combien à
mameria mois temps surtout avec lui toi
tu sais pas le genre de caractère qui
l'a pas toi tu vois ça dans les dents
ont dit non mais moi je sais je sais le
mari que j'ai eu au tel lot l'hôtel lot
de l'enseignement qui s'essaient à
l'hôtel ou un chanteur [ __ ] jaloux j'ai
vu à l'opéra mais enfin le principal
c'est tout mari voilà ce que je veux
tout le reste n'a pas d'importance
j'insère j'ai pas de famille moi ni
frère ni mon frère personnes elle nous
sommes sur le monde toi et moi
alors c'est pas ton cas meirieu du pape
ni le vatican qui nous font vivre à ses
tons marron avec une fille qui verra si
tu penses aux emprunts dont on ne sait
pas encore là on n'y a plus vite
pourquoi pas un merci du programme sa
sale boulot a dit attends attends fait
le poireauter parce que j'ai fumé tout
jamais laver les dents qui font alors ça
c'est de partir à temps
au fait où sont infinies marion nous on
verra bien après comedia comédiens 26 et
pas lui
quelqu'un qui seront près des cages ni
dans ton compte là tu es sûre qui se
doutent de rien de rien de nous ait un
peu idiot alors nommé fires tu vois que
tu tweets et des comme atelier dire la
vérité
bah oui voilà bientôt lui distille même
pas question de dire ça quoi
par questions lui dire car tu as tu fait
de laisser continuer à croire que c'est
pas parce que je me marie pour te faire
plaisir que je vais renoncer à lui donc
tu as tu penses pas et il a continué à
le voir oui elle va ce sera comme mode
c'est moi que ça regarde et alpine aux
jaloux comme il est dit non mais j'en
ferai ce que je voudrais albino mais je
veux garder un oeil à nous dans ma vie
et je regarderai pas puisque mon mariage
est une comédie autant voilà jouer sur
tous les tableaux
un bon moi je m'amuserai il faut bien
une petite pente à dire de même l'ès tu
es malade je suis malade je suis pas mu
est à l'eau en six ans c'est toi mon
cher je le sentais mais pourquoi tu n'as
pas appelé plus tôt je ne te dis pas
comment j'étais là la fièvre oui mais
pour toi je me serais levé
même avec la fièvre comme je viens de le
faire maintenant tu sais on n'en meurt
pas tout de même comme non maintenant je
disais couci couça a nommé faux-pas
trappe et tu sais bah elle mon talent
des sens
le soir naturellement le remonte de
l'aspirine pour le moment que je
t'appelle - en passant j'ai essayé tu
sais j'ai essayé deux fois au mois deux
fois personne ne répondait personne pour
le moment
eh bien je suis debout pour encore une
heure et puis je m'y colle baoli barbe
le goût du jeu mais recolle mais oui
toujours
mais moi qui veux tu je pense mais oui
bien sûr mais au tus et des fois il me
prend une rage de nouveau resté à sion
fermé mais non mon chéri c'est pas
possible
mais tu penses comme je serai contente
et heureuse mais adriano ne dis pas de
bêtises il veut venir ici venir tout de
suite maintenant ça c'est pas possible
alors comment non à couthenans et coûte
cher et qu'on dit demain à de demain
peut-être il faut absolument venir
maintenant non non ils n'ont écouté un
coutelier anneaux sois gentil de
réfléchir comment on pourrait tenir
maintenant mais c'est pas pour moi tu
peux ans mais mais tu dois tenir compte
aussi de ma famille mais tu sais bien
que je suis comme comme prisonnière
cheryl si tu le sais alors je t'en prie
à de yano je t'en prie n'ajoute pas ma
fatigue à ma tristesse tu sais que pour
te voir jouer n'importe quoi écoute pour
écoute écoute situe à 6
tu sais ce que je fais je sors et c'est
moi qui viens pas annoncer ce qu'on fait
ça ça fait ça n'est rien il n'y a pas
d'autre solution mais qu'est ce que tu
veux que ça me fascine une bouffée d'air
ça me faire du bien
c'est en tout cas je te rassure 1 1 oh
tu vois comme tu es bon alors on dit
handidanse à 8h10
disons un quart d'heure imparti midi ou
à la non non non non tu me dis toi au
vieil empire d'accord bon ma chérie tu
m'as temps là j'arrive tout de suite a
tout de suite mon chéri
[Musique]
j'ai compris tout de suite de celle
monde essayages et à quelle heure et il
est presque 7
mais comment s'est-il calvino ne soit
pas encore non on alla se pouvait tarder
encore à puce pour aller et venir sans
avoir d'explication à donner guillon
nous verrons merci monsieur
excusez-moi de vous avoir dérangé
jusqu'ici mais aujourd'hui je ne pouvais
absolument pas sortir comment va-t-elle
sa crosse koussa j'admirais ça vous
plaît au palais mètres de là presque
mort
quels coloris quelle composition a je
crois qu'elle est rare ou à merveille
maintenant ou essayons nous ici ça ira
très vite pour moi belle et bénéficie
guéret vous que tous ces murs là mon
épée classé monument historique mais
aussi par les gens du vatican c'est
parce que cette maison des portes du
vatican une propriété exclusive
monuments historiques
si si nous sommes classés vous et placer
ma vous payez votre noyau à personne
c'est à dire qu'il ya là deux ans le
vatican a acheté tout l'îlot ces
messieurs sont venus ont regardé
examiner les murs les peintures et chine
a payé comptant
quel seigneur m'a c'est ce qu'on dit
toujours même à l'étranger
parce que rio j'ai fait l'école de haute
couture à paris
sanogo est bien à paris aussi il dit on
dit que le vatican est immensément riche
mais il faut dire que nous avons eu la
chance d'avoir dans nos relations
oui en somme un ami de ma fille 1 ces
grands aristocrates vous saviez qui sont
de toutes les cérémonies importantes ce
qui porte ses beaux costumes avec la
fraise et l'épée moche tu vois je vois
la vérité et vous savez la vérité c'est
que sans la différence de classe cette
petite là vous savez elle a repris son
chemin dieu sait jusqu'où maman pourtant
pas dit que le pape avait un esprit très
très très démocratique le pape oui bien
sûr mais ma finirait jamais ennuyer le
pape pour une affaire personnelle un
enjeu la première place et c'est bientôt
terminé voilà voilà
alors à la taille est à sa place au loup
relève avec des bébés nés alors en
définitive nous adoptons la robe longue
à jean fait beaucoup en ce moment la
ligne cardinal c'est exactement ça aline
cardinal si oui à peu de choses près
alors des cent des voix la marche et au
piano car nokia va bien mais la balle a
doucement tu aurais vous non pas vous
et vous avancez voilà où une amie
ravignan une baleine one à l'univers
mois encore vol à la trace et albino va
ouvrir je fais entrer oui tu peux
chanter et églises ne parle pas trop à
celle où la jeunesse
accident le pilote tu vois je suis belle
à elle te plaît bellissima je vous salue
monsieur louis sort celui-là non mais
c'est le couturier
vous aviez toujours parlé d'une
couturière elle a toujours été question
d'un couturier leur non non non d'une
couturière quelque chose qui ne te plaît
pas albino si tu vois des faux dit le
mon chéri philo il est toujours m'a
certainement dit toujours sans bouger né
le 9 parfois dans le coup non je crois
que ça va très bien d'ailleurs j'y
connais rien pulsé oui je comprends
monsieur à d'autres idées en tête
l ajustement d'autres idées en tête je
vous libère mademoiselle vous pouvez
vous déshabiller merci monsieur tu viens
maman tout ça moi des marolles moi je
peux le faire ici aussi il y en a pour
une minute mais s'est placé au
déshabillage c'est le fiancé alors non
vous ne pensez pas maintenant je vais un
moment parle avec maman tu viens
allemand images
et vous
[Applaudissements]
alors là vous avez vu que en définitive
j'avais fait la ligue cardinal mais
c'était pas facile
cardinal qu'elle cardinal à cardinal
cardinal marc claudia cardinale hausse
est le dernier modèle de l'élégance et
de la distinction
vous devez être heureux aussi
moi oui vous devez être heureux de ce
qui se prépare ah oui oui en effet je je
me souhaite d'être heureuse on ne sait
jamais mais je vous le souhaite
ah oui oui on ne sait jamais oui vous
avez un caractère prudent à ce choix
ça vaut mieux vous aurez moins d
illusion c'est quand exactement
ces jours-ci dès le début des vacances
des vacances
j'enseigne vacances scolaires à
professeur m marc électro hip hop hop
hop hop non non je suis instituteur pas
pom pom pom pom
à oui oui les vacances de pâques alors
voilà or en enseignements ça va conforme
de jon lester qui plus tard sont des
soutiens de la civilisation
or a alors madame a dit que toutes ces
fresques avait été acheté par le vatican
ouais
oui oui qu'ils avaient payé comptant ma
de grands seigneurs des soldes seniors
ce qui nous reste dans cette époque de
décadence général marc en france aussi
d'ailleurs
je parle de la france parce que moi j'ai
fait l'école de couture à paris et bien
à paris c'est le règne du faux semblant
aujourd'hui ma ma manado blesse et là
qui sauve la civilisation va tenter de
la sortir un petit moment
avec monsieur mes excuses mon trésor je
dois choisir mon voile ça ne peut plus
attendre
non non tu n'as pas le droit de venir
mais pourquoi j'étais confiant alors
jeté les dit tu ne peux pas je je ne
comprends pas alors qu'il laisse pas
maman ses défauts bien sûr et peut-on
savoir si le marié choisi la voile à
dieu l'amour à ses bijoux
la mariée coup qu'est ce que c'est que
ces bobards des coups tu ne fais pas ça
ne va pas faire voilà c'est ce que je
dis bobards superstition ça porte
malheur et moi je tiens en bonheur des
appels là c'était peut-être des
superstitions mais ça ne coûte rien de
respecter on ne sait jamais a alors si
ça ne coûte rien bon alors maintenant
mais si nous ne faisons pas attendre
monsieur jeu phare avec lui mais toi
maman tu viens me prendre après merci
non non non tu n'assiste pas toi tu
n'assistait pas soient raisonnables même
avis elle ne veut plus faire un pas seul
dans les rues je comprends la pudeur
mais à ce moment là ça devient exagéré
et tout ça par amour pour celui là à
vous vous pouvez dire vous êtes gâtés
1 alors allons-y aux mets toi je reste
là tu attends tu travailles oui je
verrai j'attends je travaille de la non
mais tu étais en retard ce soir tu nous
as yet
est-ce que tu commencerait à faire
l'indépendance
on en reparlera ciao ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que monsieur refus maintenant ils
devront m puis vous vous emballez à non
j'adore
alors rien qu'est ce que ça signifie
apportez-moi nos points ce qui n'est pas
la peine que vous demandiez des conseils
mais sverkos et ensuite vous voulez en
faire à votre tête
écoutez idowu faisant ceci quand elle
arrivera qui emportera 2 de whisky mais
la demoiselle n'a jamais vu le whisky
pourquoi voudriez vous lui faire prendre
cette habitude dans ce soir et doit en
bois oui si ça lui fera du bien elle est
souffrante un petit peu de drake
alors mieux un grog avec quelques
gouttes des gouttes de code laissez moi
faire monsieur le comte laissez moi
faire mon isabelle au mon amour quand tu
es tout essoufflé et en moteur tu as de
la fière des mois affreuse égoïste je
suis obligé à sortir mais non at il ya
dans ces mois lorsque tu as compris
qu'après ces trois jours sans devoir je
n'en pouvais plus grands moi non plus
mais plus adriano tu ne peux pas savoir
revoir en tout cas merci merci pour tes
merveilleuses couleurs qui m'ont fait
tellement plaisir
j'espère qu'elles ne donneront pas la
maigreur n'ont pas de nom pas de danger
je voulais seulement que tu pense un peu
à moi de temps en temps à les regarder
vois tu vas y en a une qui ne me quitte
pas les autres robots mais l'appartement
mais je t'en supplie ne m'envoie plus
pourquoi
à cause de ma mère et de mon oncle aussi
sympa qui me les envoie alors une vie
impossible en posant des questions du
matin au soir parce que tu as aussi un
oncle qui habite chez toi en ce moment
oui mais ça n'avait pas vraiment là bas
je m'emballe pas
moi tu m'écoutes mal tu voyais les lui
tu comprends son retour d'une autre
génération que toi d'un autre milieu le
tiers ces fleurs qui arrive comme ça si
souvent ils ne comprennent pas l eau qu
avec un peu plus tôt et comprennent mal
y pense que j'ai une vie cachée et
malhonnêtes sont malhonnêtes oise à ce
sont ces contrariétés avec ton nom qui
tourne et sa fièvre je comprends tout
moi je suis tout en nerfs tu sais le
coeur le foie l'estomac
la moindre chose mes nerfs se croit
jeter parce qu'il foule sans fâcher j'ai
de la fièvre ah mais ça ne va plus du
tout petit dans ma petite fille chérie
un tout ce que tu me dis me renforce
dans le projet que j'ai formés et dont
je voulais absolument de table bonjour
mademoiselle le modèle fut sorti
aujourd'hui
mademoiselle gagnerie merci isole je
portais d'office la grotte pour
mademoiselle salue enfin sûrement du
bien et le whisky le monsieur pour merci
merci et lui avait dit que j'avais la
grille à bas en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils
avaient compris ta fiévreux n'en manque
pas ça va c'est moi tu m'avais parlé
d'un projet celui pour lequel je voulais
tenter voir aujourd'hui ces trois jours
sont rencontrés m'ont été trop pénible
j'avais compris qu'il me fallait prendre
une décision
et bien que les prix aient ce que tu
viens de me dire me prouve à quel point
j'avais vu juste
quelle décision tu sais que je vais les
bras si peu sur lesquelles je ne
transige pas
je sais adriano je sais je ne supporte
pas le mensonge notamment la duplicité
jeu je veux vivre au grand jour depuis
que le connaissant je n'ai pas voulu que
tu dis est de ma maîtresse c'est oui je
ne voulais pas qu'il puisse être dit que
j'avais usé de mon nom de mon prestige
de ma position pour séduire et détourner
une jeune fille comme toi mais puisque
c'est adriano tu ne détournez père ça a
peut-être mais si je vit séparé de ma
femme depuis les premiers temps de notre
mariage
je n'en suis pas moins toujours mariée
et or si tu étais ma maîtresse
et si un jour tu attends d un enfant 20
voile dans quelle situation nous ne
saurions mais tous les deux un nom crois
moi la mort pour toi est trop grand pour
laisser la porte ouverte à quoi que ce
soit qui puisse le
garnir l'assombrir ou le gâter d'autre
part je viens de constater il m'est
insupportable de ne pas devoir tous les
jours et de ne pas avoir du tout si tu
es obligé de garder la chance de rester
comme l'autre batteur en faction devant
ta fenêtre sans avoir le droit de monter
chez toi ô moun on voit ça c'est plus
possible
bon alors qu'est ce que tu veux voir ta
mère lui dire la vérité quelle vérité
que nous nous aimons que j'ai décidé de
faire annuler mon mariage et qu'elle
veuille bien me considérer désormais
comme ton fiancé puisque je t'épouserais
le jour où je serai libre tu as décidé
de de faire annuler son mariage
quand on y est et tu ne pouvais pas le
décidé plus tôt
depuis un an nous connaissons j'ai
compris que c'était indispensable
tu dis que tu m as tu eu le pont il a
décidé quoi il appelle là non pour que
tu saches que tu m'aimes voilà ce que je
retiens et moi j'étais à toi tout de
suite avait il ya donc j'étais prête à
tout à te suivre notre donné à l'est
avec toi ou tu voudrais marier ou pas je
m'en fichais toi qu'a bâlois n'ont pour
vouloir être mon fiancé tutu en retard
mais pourquoi tu as un peu tard tu
passais mais pourquoi tu viens de me
dire que tu m'aimais il n'est jamais
trop tard pour décider d'être heureuse
tu es sûr de l'obtenir cette annulation
tu évidemment tu as fait de la maison
quelle maison du vatican c'est bien
placé quoi
je veux dire que mon cas fait partie de
ceux prévus pour l'annulation
si je n'en étais pas su je ne serais pas
là mais où serait tu tu dis je ne serais
pas là où cela que je voulais dire sans
être sûre de cette annulation qui ne
verrait plus même si adriano situe même
mais sur la perspective de cette
annulation tu préfèrerais de plus me
voir
voilà lourds tels que tout le comprend
avec tout ce qui te colle à la peau et
dont une popote défaire le
qu'en-dira-t-on la société là l'église
ne pas venir en voiture adriano de
miracle c'est que malgré tout ça contre
moi contre nous ça quand même assise là
tes côtés dans ce café bombée je ne
comprends pas manger mais pourquoi tu es
nerveux ainsi que quelle mauvaise raison
sur youtube quelques réelles je m'énerve
je m'énerve parce que tu m'as l'once
comme ça brutalement tu vas faire de moi
ta femme compte c'est pas une raison
pour être ici motion alors tu dois être
heureux
mais bon on va dit moi ça mais le pleure
forme en amont chérie tu es heureuse à
le pleure pas je suis heureuse mais je
n'y crois pas à quoi notre bonheur
cette annulation ce mariage ta femme est
d'accord pour demander l'annulation
oui non mais notre âme nous avons déjà
parlé et tu lui as dit que tu souhaitais
cette annulation qui est énorme épouse
est pas encore à quoi alors ce n'est
parfait et pourquoi ma femme n'a pas
vraiment construit ta femme est si peu
quelles étaient tes de confiance se
perdre d'accord mais de perdre pour que
tu sois euros avec une autre fille paula
est incapable d'en bas se ressemblent
elle est trop bien née tu connais mal
les femmes nous sommes nés puis nous
sommes vaches
reportage et chaque mois je vois que tu
le vois pas ma forme comme et admettons
qu'elle accepte dans combien de temps
leur actu du coi l'annulation oui quinze
jours à moi oh non je dis donc c'est
plus long mais là c'est toute une fois
séduire ça peut durer je ne sais pas moi
non
peut-être moins remarquer tu veux que
nous restions prendre un nom fiancée
nous nous verrons grange où nous sommes
obligés de nous cacher comme nous le
faisons c'est impossible et pourquoi ma
mère et mon oncle ne marchera pas non
non non eh ben j'ai retrouvé aussi pour
ne surtout pas pourquoi parce que
d'abord je ne soit plus là il n'était
venu qu'en passant
et puis tu ne le connais pas au nom ou
la la c'est un homme de rollin presque
dans notre monde
il est sicilien il suffirait qu'il te
vois il compromet tout de suite là les
fleurs les absences il manquera la porte
ben non maintenant fages à dire qu'ils
n'ont ils pensent que cette annulation
est une excuse qu'elle n'est pas sûre et
qu'au fond tu viendrais lui demander de
couvrir des relations qui croiraient
coupable mamelles telle que je la
connais n'imaginerait pas autre chose
pense déjà au chagrin à quelle heure est
de savoir que depuis un an nous nous
voyons en secret le sait l'impact
existent pour moi et comment je croyais
que tu lui parler de moi quelquefois oui
moi aussi tu l'as réfléchi un esthétisme
fort réfléchis tu dois confondre mais
avec tiéné je ne sais pas mais jamais
j'ai pu dire une chose pareille
enfin pour ma mère tu es tu es
l'architecte du vatican un homme très
distinguée très aimable mais tu pas une
seconde à jeter un regard sont celles ci
n'ont pas non plus j'y pense
adriano et plus je suis sûr que tu cours
rien échec en parlant la mer dont tu
sais tu ne connais pas
sous ses airs de bonne femme un peu
simple une vraie tête de mule mais moi
tels que tu me vois je ne fais ni plus
onic plus bas parce qu'elle veut comment
depuis à non j'ai pu être assez maligne
n'importe quels signaux là quand j'y
pense je me dis que je dois être quand
même assez forte dans mon genre c'est
vrai ça tu dis que tu es le mensonge
tu dis que j'en suis incapable si je
n'avais pas si mentir aurions nous pu
continuer à nous voir peut-être
découvrir à tous un jour que je suis une
vraie menteuse une équipe aux cercles
qui n'est pas ici que ferais tu si tu le
découvres ait quoi que que tu es une
coquine par exemple à jeffrey un retour
complet sur moi même ça ça veut dire
quoi eh bien je comprendrais que l'on
peut être droit et avoir des scrupules
et en même temps une coque que tu
puisses quand même dire non mais je sais
bien que ce ne serait pas possible et
que ce jour là tu me déporterai hélas
c'est un risque qu'on ne le dit pas plus
tu as raison tu as raison mais charles
ont sérieusement parce que je vais te
dis on va certainement surprendre mais
enfin j'ai tourné j'ai retourné la chose
voilà pour échapper à ma mère et à ma
famille et pour que nous puissions nous
nous voir comme tu le souhaites plus et
même autrement
en attendant ton annulation oui je ne
vois qu'un moyen lequel il faut que tu
me permettent de me marier
commences à te marier mais avec tout et
n'importe qui en fou tu touches comme
moi en fait mais les phoques mais pour
quoi faire
maurice lévy pour être vivement que mais
je fais comme toi je me marie jeanne à
faire ça que ça ne colle pas ce fait
donné mon mariage
mais puisque tu t'occupes breton
annulation à toi tu seras encore mieux
placé pour faire avancer la mélangeant
belle aventure complètement folle où je
ne veux pas que tu dis des choses
pareilles ont fait au total 58 ans
comment comment autant puis mais tu
semble regretter ce que je peux faire
d'autre
puisque tu n'es pas d'accord non je suis
pas d'accord je ne serai jamais je te
dit nettement non non pas non plus haut
les dés sont jetés les dés que d aider
adriano l'aider
tu ne permet pas de mariée c'est tout
c'est la vie c'est ma vie s'est excusé
une drôle de fille isabelle et que tu as
des idées comme personne qui croit aussi
je ne te connaissais pas comme je te
connais tu me ferait peur parfois
mais tu me connais heureusement
maintenant faut que demandait qu'on
voudrait qu'on s'inquiétait on les
connaît tous depuis ce jour commence à
être moi tu peux en tout cas si c'est la
fièvre de la planète tu sais la fièvre
mais ce n'est pas vrai tué la veille
c'est avec vous monsieur compte que je
trouve ma fille avec moi en effet jamais
ça va vous tranquilliser votre fille ne
court aucun danger
elle m'avait dit que malgré son état sa
fièvre
ça devait absolument sortir pour une
visite indispensable mais jamais au
grand jamais il me serait venu à l'idée
ça vous déplaît t-il madame que cette
visite était pour moi donc je ne sais
pas davantage je ne dirais pas cela me
déplaît et ça me surprend vous
comprendrez je suis très très surpris
quand j'ai vu qu isabelle a tardé à
rentrer j'avais dit à maman où j'allais
oui ça me dit toujours où elle va vous
en doutez madame ne serait-il permis de
vous parler une minute à des yanomami
savais la gérer ce que je dois
comprendre je sens entre vous deux une
certaine complicité est ce que je me
trompe vous avez là vous n'allez pas
m'apprendre que vous compromettez ma
fille unique
c'est bien joli de s'introduire chez les
gens sous prétexte de voir leur fera est
ce que monsieur front mais y'a fraises
dudka et frasques ne confondons pas il
me dirait madame de vous entendre dire
que je me suis introduit chez vous je
dis pas un cambrioleur isabelle je crois
que le moment est venu de tout dire à ta
mère a dit à l'ats s'est enfin dit déjà
tout ce que je redoutais il vous l'a
tutoyée vous un monsieur du un monsieur
du vatican quel coup donné à coeur de
faire les malins mais tout est très sain
je vous prie de consentir à ce
qu'isabelle là soit à moi même si je ne
puis encore l'épousé voilà vous ne
pouvez pas mon pouzy vous êtes mariés
mais l'amour l'amour la force
incommensurable de l'amour que bien le
nôtre ne redoute rien ni personne
je vaincrai tous les obstacles un jour
là un jour ou l'autre
j'obtiendrai l'annulation de mon mariage
mais jusque là je vous prie je vous
conjure par isabelle la y consentent
aussi de me considérer comme votre futur
gendre isabelle là et moi sommes fiancés
les amours monsieur le comte les un
homme d'honneur et pour des zones où
comme vous le divorce peut exister en it
elle pas de divorce n'a jamais à bâle
c'est parfait
nous aurons tout son divorce croyant je
vous l'avoué j'ai reçu un coup un coup
très dur pour une mère mais j'ai mieux
que les choses soient claires mousse
naturellement je vous demanderai le
temps de me retourner enfin de réfléchir
souligne juste de toute façon la pauvre
chérie n'est pas bien en ce moment
dès qu'il sera rétabli je veux l'emmener
se refaire al-anon parent chez son oncle
en sicile non content je vois qu'à nous
a aussi parlé de son nom et je serai
très heureux de le rencontrer si le faux
la main à la leo c'est un sauvage il
vous faudrait peut-être leur ses
manières un peu brusques
mais c'est un sauvage il ya de grandes
propriétés près de syracuse pâtir accuse
avec des champs d'orangers et magnifie
la commune invité isabelle qui est aussi
sa fiole parce que c'est lui
j'ai accepté de renvoyer chez lui en
attendant vous contant le rsa n'est ce
pas monsieur compte il faut qu'elle se
retape votre petite isabelle alors ce
temps va je réfléchirai
peut-être même j'en dirai un mot à son
oncle mais en face on verra eh bien et
pendant ce temps là moi j'ai activerait
les démarches pour mon annulation oui ça
dure un petit bout de temps je crois un
en quad ou madame ces annulations à tout
départ de la sainte rose bien sûr la
sainte roth
oui c'est le tribunal qui statuait au
vatican sur les cas d'annulation oui on
en vient à bout croyez moi et bien
isabelle là tu ne dis rien ma fièvre
relégation
excusez-nous blessure mais comment alors
très content howie pas toi je nage dans
le bonheur ça par pages je te téléphone
c'est ça et si isabelle la théorie c'est
moi qui vont répondre être merci les
hommages
[Applaudissements]
tu vois maman comme toi elle ne peut
vivre que dans la vérité
[Musique]
mais c'est ça veut dire qu'en bois
d'orme et toi ça fait plus alors je me
suis dit lui est arrivé quelque chose
mais qu'est ce que tu voulais qu'ils
méritent
ce qui me plaît tout contenu peuvent ils
ressemblent pas un mastroianni mais
c'est un monsieur
il sait parler aux femmes d'horizons
dommage de match ni rien à faire le
comorien comment il va demander
l'annulation qu'elle annulation c'est
des histoires tout ça avant qu'une
question des mutations qu aurait eu
quatre enfants
la siv classe entre c'est la pilule tout
ça c'est vous dire mais pour être
amoureux de toi alors ça il aa dima dima
qu'en sait-il que je plaisent tellement
à un homme comme lui moi ta tristement
moi pourquoi quel homme comme lui mais
je ne sais pas un homme un homme
compliqué sérieux religieux mais ma foi
je lui plais tellement devrait pas être
sans type et lui et lui pourquoi est ce
qui me plaît tellement à moscou lui il
te plaît parce que c'est un monsieur
et toi tu lui plaît parce que tu es
ponam alors qu'est-ce que je suive une
organe tous les aristocrates sont les
mêmes il aime le peuple par vi au
vatican comme ailleurs entre toi et lui
si je me retrouve avec en tout cas lui
c'est du vent là c'est le courant d'air
des couloirs du vatican les secourir
quand tu m'énerves fait venir on va bien
toi de moi 23 noir alors j'ai tout
arranger arranger quoi elle va ta
convalescence syracuse 80 auraient pu
prévenir tu avais un compte
heureusement je suis une rapide en tous
cas tort à tout ton temps pour ton
voyage de noces il te laissera
tranquille me dis donc il va falloir
trouver un truc pour les cartes postales
la carte postale bien celle que tu
devras lui envoyer de syracuse
puisque vous allez en voyage données de
noces à venise du musée
[Musique]
tu connais syracuse benyamine au moi non
mais ça valait le crème ou regardent
homélie ses mots à tout enlever les
médias vidéo tout sauvadet dans un mois
une nouvelle vie va commencer pour moi
une nouvelle vie quel d'autres sont
venus aujourd'hui le 23 avril le 23 le
23 avril j'en suis certain c'est mon
anniversaire
mon anniversaire aujourd'hui ils
savaient pas et bien maintenant monsieur
le comte le sait et bah oui donc pas
l'enjeu de faire un cadeau aux me soit
dont il si j'y tiens absolument voyons
qui te ferait plaisir une vespa francis
tôt le colisée hausse et robin suivra en
modèle réduit
quel âge as-tu aujourd'hui 37 en robe
c'est mon argent mais enfin dix ans près
1 le 23 voile alors une date à ne plus
oublier date heureuse et mémorable
anniversaire de benyamin you le 23 avril
c'est noté là
et moi je remettrai autour du 23 mai une
sorte de nouvel anniversaire
ah oui je peux pas encore t'expliquer
c'est bien monsieur le comte
elle doit commencer à reprendre des
forces et des couleurs parler des
orangers de syracuse comment un homme
dont je parlais tout seul
[Musique]
et
tant mieux mais j'entends ça donne je
n'attends rien moi je ne sais pas il
m'avait sans rire
oui
[Musique]
e
et
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas mal avec cette subite
frénésie de gymnastique et des sports
monsieur le comte doit savoir qu'il a
toujours était jusqu'ici contre le bon
sens je servais bien mignon change il
est un âge où la jeunesse
hésitant dans les articulations
c'est sans doute pour cela que le seul
compte fait des assouplissements voilà
mais monsieur le comte est encore jeune
bien sûr mais je tiens à rester de la
gymnastique que je passerai à la boxe
alors on met sur le compte
on verra alors des choses surprenantes
sur quoi je me rappelle que le 23 avril
le jour de mon anniversaire à mon dieu
tient ton cadeau que j'ai encore oublié
non mais seul quand il passera de ses
joueurs je me rappelle qu'à ce jour là
monsieur le comte m'a annoncé pour le 23
mai une sorte de second anniversaire
pour lui
ah oui mais je voulais dire moralement
nous sommes le 23 mai 23 mai aujourd'hui
oui
puis je me permettent de demander à
monsieur le comte si l'anniversaire en
question a bien eu lieu
les oisiens inutile voire je t'avais dit
que je relèverai gironnais les choses
comme je le souhaite
tu vas voir en pleine forme à ce propos
le château j'attends ce matin la visite
de madame la comtesse sitôt qu'elle sera
là fait la rentrée je vais m'habiller en
attendant vous bien les choses car ce
matin avec ces jeunes voyous dont je
vais être en stage attrapé t'ai déjà dit
mille fois d'une propulsion ce langage
est tellement plus agréable de ne pas
entendre des mots d'argot qui traînent
partout at on aussi car les ont jamais
surveillé mais bien aux attentes
puisqu'on prend bas c'est qu'avant je me
réveillais toujours facilement le gunner
est maintenant assainie restant à table
reste 11 i do longtemps l'amour est
agréable la fnac l'arrêté comprends pas
je testerai ce soir pour que ce soir si
tu as été sage comme tu dis c'est du
temps de nos fiançailles le poids avant
tout aller
l'addition
[Musique]
c'est toi
et ben oui c'est moi valeur mais que se
passe-t-il mais je ne sais pas un
instant en dérangement
oui mais maintenant ça va oui oui
maintenant tout va bien et bien bonjour
et bien bonjour comment es-tu le mieux
du monde
oui oui heureusement très hostile n'a
pas senti quand en plus je ne sais pas
moi et tout le temps depuis temps
voiture de syracuse suffit que nous le
sommes revus voilà j'ai senti qu est
heureuse de me retrouver tout séjour sim
mais moi tu sais il ya des moments où je
pense terriblement à toi moi aussi quand
je ne sais pas je peux pas te dire
exactement
et bah tiens hier soir moi j'ai beaucoup
pensé à toi très fortement même les
j'étais très heureux et tu vas me dire
si tu l'a senti et si tu étais heureuse
toi aussi sûrement à 10h30 à 10h30
j'étais couché tu étais heureuse très
heureuse oh oui et des imbéciles
prétendent que les antennes n'existe
porn
et toi oui chez le cardinal la talonner
oui à un dîner avec mon père alors je
les laissais parler et tout le groupe
la pendule a sonné 10h30 j'ai presque
sursauter et le cardinal a dit tiens
tiens
adriano se promener en ce moment il
était à la campagne des bas c'était vrai
mon nom j'étais la campagne avec toi et
nous étions très heureux
alors comme ça te dit chez les cardinaux
et à 10h30 tu te promènes dans la
campagne dont il fait partie du sacré
collège je travaillais pour nous ah oui
pour l'annulation
oui mais je crois qu'on finira par y
arriver tu verras et j'ai une surprise à
j'attends ma femme d'un instant talons
cette femme et cet autre ville sera
capitale
mais tout me laisse croire que les
choses iront comme sur du velours
alors tu ne dis rien je suis né je
t'écoute adriano je t'écoute tu sais je
je pense à cette annulation pour
laquelle tu te donne tellement dommage
j'ai des scrupules commence à un esprit
pull
enfin je veux dire que même si tu y
renonçait même s'il n'était pas possible
que tu que tu l'obtiens
comment as tu dis
qu'est ce que j'ai dit qu'il n'était pas
possible que tu look tass
mais que voilà un langage châtié jamais
tu n'aurais vraiment c'est une phrase
pareille avant avant pas ne me tue pas
fait souvent remarquer que je parlais
d'une façon trop relâché toi tu me l'a
dit il m'a dit qu'il fallait que je
surveille mon langage que que je ma fine
je ma fille mon cher de ma ville et bien
[ __ ] à toi comme tu te moques de moi
non je ris je m'amuse c'est bon dribble
oui c'est bon c'est bon ça me donne
envie de te voir c'est si bon de rire
avec toi surtout quand tu as tonnerre
des grands jours mais bon on voit tout à
l'heure 11 heures oui je suis libre
jusqu'à 13h nous toujours vieil empire
oui très bien on a sonné ce thème lors
soit prennent moi je ne te quitte pas
une seconde à tout à l'heure tout à la
victoire mais je t'ai déjà dit que je
dis mais non j'ai pas entendu fait mon
appui fort ben je deviendrai que je peux
partir salopards il a raccroché en
premier chez
pas
comment allez vous paolucci coup ce bon
dieu pourquoi
mais pour rire un peu c'est bon de rire
non on est comme c'est gentil à vous de
venir me voir avec le sourire aux lèvres
ne suis pas toujours tout sourire avec
vous et adrian c'est aux parents vous ne
voulez pas vous asseoir
on ici débarrasser merci mais bien
mignon qu'on nous dérange pas les images
ici pour personne pour personne bien
monsieur le comte vous serez gentil de
me donner un verre d'eau des gamines ont
tout de suite madame la comtesse ou
pardon vous ne préférez par une tasse de
café
mais non vous le savez bien le matin
vers dos tout simplement c'est non non
bien sûr or ce grand de distraction à je
suis navré paula devrait avoir demandé
de venir ici alors que c'est moi qui
aurais dû aller jusqu'à non voyons nous
serons beaucoup plus tranquille ici pour
d'adapter votre mère m'en veux toujours
beaucoup non non je ne signerai
nullement d'ailleurs ma mère ne vous en
veux pas brillant non mais elle se
refuse toujours à croire que vous et moi
nous puissions vraiment le plus est elle
veut toujours espérer je crois vous
savez comme un air à pomeys
c'est une femme me rare délicatesse une
classe
merci d nyamina adrien d'euros vous
vouliez me voir
oui cher très cher
non non non à trianon je vous en supplie
ne commencez pas à prendre de grands
airs et à faire de la diplomatie
nous savons tous les deux ne pas nous
allons parler avec moi à la diplomatie
est tout à fait l'utile et j'ajouterais
que votre diplomatie personnel pourquoi
quoi qu'est-ce que la de particuliers
diplomation bien disons qu'elle n'a rien
à voir avec la diplomatie
vous êtes un grand ingénue qui veut
jouer au diplomate mais le fait est
qu'en prenant les choses de haut vous
vous noyer dans un verre d'eau et que
vous n'aviez inutile de me regarder avec
ces yeux là vous savez très bien que
nous resterons toujours bon vin dit même
en nous disant la vérité n'est ce pas
bien sûr mais plus que des amis
waouh plus je ne sais pas disons de
bezannes je suis à vous demander de bien
vouloir régulariser notre situation et
cette formule rapide me convient
d'affaires continue le temps j'aurais
trouvé inélégant de vous le faire savoir
par un avocat
on saurait été très inélégant vous avez
raison j'ai préféré vous le dire
j'y suis extrêmement sensible
mais pourquoi pour motiver ce désir mais
rien absolument rien nouveau je voudrai
régulariser notre passé à faire annuler
notre mariage
par là a à ce point là une annulation
franchement c'est normal non pas tout à
fait vous savez que je n'aime pas les
situations fossé soit elles peuvent
avoir de fâcheuses conséquences d'ordre
moral tout le monde sait maintenant ce
que nous sommes là pour l'autre vivent
chacun de son côté
quand je ne vois pas pourquoi nous
continuerions tout à fait votre avis les
piles au groupe a nous annulons dit on a
rapidement ce que je dois faire vous
avez me concentre je suppose que je veux
savoir à dire un certain nombre de
mensonges n'est ce pas ah non alors qu
aucun mensonge la vérité au contraire
toute la vérité vous voulez guérin
autres vous perdez exclure de
raisonnement un peu s'il vous plaît mon
avocat m'a affirmé à parce qu'il ya déjà
un avocat entre nous oui il me semblait
vouloir du jeune et naïf vous semble
moins coûteux lors pas où là franchement
moi je vends il mord aux dents tout de
suite et voient pas comme vérité parce
que un avocat spécialiste a pu me donner
aux toute discrétion quelques conseils
nous leur avons peut-être laissons cela
que dicte et je vous en prie l'avocat et
bien voilà qu'il est avant tout
indispensable que nous choisissions d'un
commun accord
le motif de l'annulation qui doit être
présenté au sacré collet oui c'est nous
qui devons choisir qui voulez vous je
veux dire pourquoi n'est ce pas l'avocat
tu choisirais vi qui connaît ce genre
d'affaires
voulez-vous l'incompatibilité d'humeur
ce n'est pas suffisant pour l'église
l aise comme message néglige rien nous
nous dirigerons vers le vide de forme
peut-être enfin en cherchant bien on
doit pouvoir
je voulais quelque chose de plus
d'appelés mais comment dirais-je de plus
en plus conforme à notre situation
un bis voire l'impuissance ça vous irait
qui sauf un puissant et qui moi je
plaisante
vous plaisantez je sais je sais qu'avant
va vous avez eu des maîtresses et que
vous en avez eu d'autre depuis notre
séparation certains ont même tenu à ce
qu'on ait aucun doute à ce sujet
rassurez vous je sais comme danone
connais pas précisément un sujet de
plaisanterie bah voila si nous renonçons
à cette impuissance qui vous a fait
monter sur vos égaux comme un coq
français il faut bien admettre qu il en
a existé une en ce qui vous concerne et
plus grave de l'autre c'est la puissance
à mai mais en tout cas je résidais la
seule en somme avec qui pour de
mystérieuses raisons que voulez vous mon
cher c'est vrai nous cherchons un motif
à l'annulation d'un autre mariage il est
là c'est le seul mais ne me demandez pas
de révéler officiellement mon triste
privilège
je ne ferai jamais vous n'aurez pas de
mal à le comprendre je pense
vous devez avoir une idée puisque vous
avez à ce point insisté pour me voir
alors dit là tout simplement il finit
son sens car moi aussi
oui mais quoi tomber dit vachon que j'ai
une idée
précisément arrêté elle devrait surgir
de cet entretien
alors pourquoi me creuser la tête
demandez à votre avocat ce sera plus
simple de toute façon je voulais lit je
souscris à tous qui vous conviendra vous
m'apportez les papiers et je signe je ne
peux pas être plus fair play comme
toujours et non un archange paoli qui
est maintenant que vouliez vous me
demandez à mon tour d'être un ange pour
vous ou est toujours ma maudite
curiosité je voulais savoir où ce n'est
qu'un détail bien sûr et pourquoi vous
savez brusquement ce désir de faire
annuler notre mariage qu'est ce que
c'est à vous apporter
mais je dire bien plus c'est pour être
dans une situation nette régulière on
peut laisser mes scrupules moraux en
terre vous n'en avez aucun paula vous me
connaissez c'est justement parce que je
vous connais que deux nuits non je vous
le répète ne jouit pas les diplomates
avec moi ça ne prend pas j'accepte tout
ce que vous désirez à la condition que
vous ne pourriez pas de scrupules moraux
j'ai horreur de ce genre de trucage
riez pas l'intention de vous remarqué
par hasard ouah
mais quelle idée ce serait une idée très
normal monsieur or alors là pas aulas je
vous affirme éric surtout sérah diallo
il voudrait se remarier ne peut pas
voter d'italie ce n'est pas volé mais
qu'allez vous cherchez la vava que
voulez vous devez la vérité et je la
connais la fille que vous voulez épousé
la fille quelle fille isabelle hains
ah bon parfait alors je suis espionner
en quelque sorte
oh non non non non ce n'est pas par goût
de l'espionnage quand je me suis
renseigné mais par intérêt pour vous
adriano je ne dirais pas par amour cela
vous déplairait et bien que séparés vous
n'avez jamais cessé de m'intéresser
figurines suis très flatté heureux enfin
heureux dans la mesure où cet intérêt ne
vous pousse pas à me mettre des bâtons
dans les roues
bien au contraire savez vous ai dit je
veux c'est une femme tout à fait
supérieure paula mais n'allons pas trop
loin alors vous vous connaissez cette
jeune fille du tout mais je suis au
courant
il me semble même être plus que vous
nommez au courant de quoi de sa
personnalité
il me paraît tout à fait extraordinaire
que vous ne soupçonniez pas ce que je
sais car vraiment vous ne semblez pas en
a paru vidé je crois qu'en parents marc
emig me voir là ne nous devons parler de
choses différentes
[Musique]
je suis sûr que nous renvoyer vous alors
je ne vous suis pas c'est très normal
isabella est marié à l'atria
cette jeune fille mardi très exactement
le 23 avril il ya un mois jour pour jour
dans l'église san felice selon le rite
habituel voulez vous prendre pour épouse
ici présentes oui voulez vous pour
marquer autant qu'on peut l'être devant
est récurent et avec le slam donc je
vous laisserai le document qui peut
d'ailleurs vous intéresser mais avec in
ovo liane aux instituteurs actuellement
en fonction à l'église à l'école de la
vidéo ça aux avenues des lois de rome en
ville le téléphone 22 32 40
donc je sais ce n'est pas vrai je crois
oui si calme et au silence
vous pourrez vous convaincre ici que je
n'invente rien comment avez vous été au
courant je suis comme vous pouviez
lettre mon cher comme tout le monde par
affiches les mariages sont affichés
pendant deux semaines aux portes des
mairies et des églises
je m'en vais faire un de ces scandales
mais soyez assez bons pour attendre un
moment je préfère ne pas y assister
je suis persuadé que ce serait à la fois
comique et pénible
n'oubliez pas que je reste entièrement
soumise et obéissante à vaut plus cher
désir adria
raul après les gars si vous avez fait ça
par jalousie ou dans un esprit de
vengeance
je ne vous pardonnerai jamais mais
qu'ai-je fait c'est elle qui s'est marié
pas moi mon rôle s'est borné à vous
sortir de votre rêve et à vous ouvrir
les yeux à l'eau qui grincent
c'était plutôt gentil de ma part non au
revoir
adrien non
[Applaudissements]
c'est le coup de barre
le coup de barre classique
c'est extraordinaire je me sens pas
aussi furieux que je devrais l'être mais
j'attends que tout le monde semble viala
la tête
non il n'y a pas voulu froid et lucide
je n'ai pas même que maintenant je je
vois tous très clair oui tout dans le
fond isabelle jeu l'admirent l effort
une coquine mais une coquine de classe
et qui peut dire quel est le secret
motif car il doit y en avoir a le coeur
humain les mystères du coeur rue bon eh
bien nous allons tâcher d'y voir clair
et tout de suite un monsieur monsieur
comme moi bilino polje institut
l'institut l'école note sérieuse allons
alors l'école nazario sa roue
je voudrais parler à l'instituteur
albino fabiano ici c'est l'inspecteur
principal
il est là oui ou non ça ne fait rien qui
est naturel ça classe mais oui au
téléphone au pardon monsieur contre la
paix mais non pas du tout je vois
partout en europe
bonjour allô allô
l'instituteur folie à nous c'est lui
mais ici c'est un ami de l'inspecteur
principal
oui un ami alors là je voudrais vous
parler de madame folha oui presque oui
précisément de votre femme voit alors
mais je me répète je suis un ami alors
voilà vous devriez aller vers 11h15 au
café du vieil empire vous y trouverez
votre femme
sa danse regarde à nous mais je vous
assure que vous la trouverez assagi
depuis abx a oui nous sommes comme ça
nous à l'académie nous surveillons les
instituteurs
les instituteurs et leurs familles
je ne peux vous en dire davantage aller
et vous verrez comment kouao s'il vous
plaît nolf l'hectare je me brise mais ne
plie pas et maintenant ma petite fille
tu n'as plus qu'un quart d'heure de
ventre et à nous deux ou plutôt à nos
troupes
[Musique]
la première fois aujourd'hui c'est
mademoiselle qui est en avance et
monsieur le comte qui est en retard
oui c'est la première fois il est bien
11 heures on pensait de deux minutes
seulement mademoiselle je n'ai pas
beaucoup mais il ya longtemps il se doit
alors que vous connaissez monsieur le co
je pense bien mademoiselle quand il
était tout petit garçon au comme ça
comme ça mais il n'est souvent dimanche
avec le vieux cons enfin son père je dis
dieu parce qu'aujourd'hui
comment est-il de vieux se dire son père
et le vieux comment il est comment dire
aujourd'hui il est un peu fatigué oui
fatigué c'est le mot que voulez vous les
années passent mais de son temps c'était
un grand seigneur par exemple oh la la
il faisait la pluie et le beau temps à
rome un pied au vatican à pied au
conseil municipal
je crois qu'ils en avaient eux aussi à
la cour dans la maison royale encore
inquiète aussi
c'était quelqu'un de solide vous savez
et vous ne connaissez pas et non non ça
ne m'était pas très facile et son palais
vous ne connaissez pas non plus non plus
grand ça j'aimerais bien
or une jolie demoiselle comme vous ne
manque pas d'arguments pour convaincre
son fils
voilà monsieur le comte nous sommes
importantes le peloton je pouvais pas
faire toi la demoiselle suis désolée la
belle latina pas être pas tendu le spare
la même chose
oui pas pour moi non non apporte moins
fernet branca quelque chose qui n'a pas
passé parce que le court
mais c'est quelque chose qui n'a pas
passé ça ne va pas tu t'es engagé
l'ancien shah d'iran tu as eu des
difficultés avec affable il ya du tirage
j'ai du tirage lui du tirage tout était
d'accord entendu à lamia mai puis au
dernier moment des ongles des grilles le
parce qu'au dernier moment tout lui
avouer que tu souhaites est ta liberté
pour pouvoir mais pousser et à partir de
là ça n'a plus gaz et voilà ce qu'on n'a
plus de gaz
je te l'avais dit tu te souviens je te
l'avais dit tu m'a dit qu'elle était
trop bien né pour se conduire mal je
t'ai répondu moi non je me rappelle ce
que tu me réponds qu'à eu l'air de
trouver que j'ai l'air fort en effet
mais je ne disais que ce qui est oui en
sommes axés montré la dernière dépasse
elle a été assez perf' dans les faits
leur fille perd et c'est le mauvais sens
distinguer si tu sais moi c'est bien ce
que je disais mais qu'est ce qu'elle
veut en salle c'est bien que pour le nom
de mon père je ne peux pas faire les
scandales alors elle en profite voilà
tout dis-moi dix mots adriano je
m'excuse mais est ce que ça ne serait
pas des questions d'argent à la non non
non pour l'argent on s'arrange toujours
non elle veut ni plus ni moins que nous
nous adressions directement ou pas pour
trancher notre cas et ça ça peut se
faire
d'habitude non seulement tu sais avec
l'appui de mon père aussi bien elle est
capable d'y arriver et si le parti donné
raison mais si si et il me donne tort
après le oui je peux m'adresser à qui
non non non je ne veux pas je refuse je
veux l'annulation normal simplement et
tout de suite
d'ailleurs maintenant je crois au fait
accompli je les mets tous devant le fait
accompli
c'est à dire je t'enlève c'est décidé
c'est déjà fait et qui arrive le
scandale qu'avec la fin du monde je
quitterais même rome ou s'il le faut
vous dire l'entité monsieur le comte de
non seules me suis pas certain encore
mais je ferai peut-être partie de la
suite du cardinal les gars auquel belles
choses ce serait pour vous messieurs
alors ça y est je me suis tu pars avec
moi que décide est juste car avec moi
maintenant comment fais tu me suis c'est
tout plus rien n'existe que nous un
geste fait seulement un geste qui me
prouve sa sincérité piano piano adriano
réfléchissent annonçant ne réfléchit
plus c'est de me savoir j'ai trop
réfléchi je passe aux actes
nous partons mais tu sais bien que quand
je ne peux pas pourquoi pourquoi une
foutue parent pourquoi pas la fin
en ce qui le concerne il ne s'agit pas
des scrupules moraux qui m'ont fait
reculer mois de jour en jour alors quoi
ta mère non mais qui te dis que moi de
mon côté je n'ai pas à surmonter la toi
c'est toi qui m'a toujours dit voilà je
te le dis alors alors alors si ce qu'on
fait sa vérité tu t'en servir à contre
moi on verra bien alors
alors on change
figure toi on change
j'ai changé et c'est toi qui m'a
transformé on peut pas passer des heures
comme je lé fais avec toi sans être
influencés ça commençait à ressentir
certaine délicatesse de sentiments ce
que tu as ptt scrupules moraux
tu me croiras ou non ça m'est égal je
les ressens moi aussi comme toi
au début j'étais prête à tout parce
qu'au fond je ne t'ai mais peut-être pas
vraiment j'étais impressionné mais
autant par ta situation que par toi je
fais je me voyais comtesse alors jeunes
galopeurs galopeurs que je voyais en toi
c'était celui qui pouvait me sortir de
ma famille de changer ma vie au fond
j'étais égoïste je ne pensais qu'à moi
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tu m'as tu m'as forcée à
réfléchir beaucoup va sentir
certaines nuances à marie mais comme tu
disais alors aujourd'hui je ne suis plus
du tout la même
isabelle là je t'aime pour toi je ne
conclus avec moi je me suis donné à toi
et quel que soit l'avenir savez égal
j'accepte de rester chez moi
enfermé avec ma mère du moment que je le
fais pour toi et je ne veux pas je ne
veux pas qu'à cause de moi pour moi tu
fasse une bêtise à scandales qui te
rendrai très malheureux j'en suis sûr tu
me manques tu m'aimes je n'en demande
pas plus ici je te permets m j'aimerais
je deviendrais folle je serais capable
de faire une folie
ce n'est pas croyable
tu ne me crois pas non non non je veux
dire une telle transformation est à
peine croyable ça c'est trop c'est trop
c'est vrai tu sais c'est bref si ça
continue comme ça je finis à ladornac
trouvant jusqu'à ce monsieur qui
arrivent là même contredit pas je
t'expliquerai bonjour petite surprise
n'est ce pas je vois que l'on m'avait
bien renseignés c'est parfait qui se
perd sony et ses intervenants
c'est moi monsieur tu dois plutôt vous
demandez est ce qui vous plaît dans sa
prison mais je vais vous expliquer
monsieur et le conte adriano gangloff et
un ami de ma famille maman le connaîtra
bien maman à dejan ou je te présente mon
mari commence à tomber
tu ne vas pas me dire vous ne saviez pas
qu'isabella était marié je la prends
non non albi nous non adriano ne le
savais pas et quand tu es arrivé
d'ailleurs justement je m'apprêtais à
lui dire je n'ai pas pu faire avant
leconte revient d'un assez long voyage
et
oui je je reviens d'amérique que par
bateau
et elle ne vous avais pas dit positon
marié se comprend qu'elle n'ait pas
voulu me l'avouer tout de suite pourquoi
nous avons été fiancée fiancée vous deux
voilà tu sais tout albino et caen avant
mon départ mais c'est pour me changer
les idées
notre mariage rien passé du possible que
je suis partie oubliée isabelle là en
amérique donne moi ta main gauche
isabelle là tu ne portes pas ton
alliance et un pack de fiançailles
mais voilà sont dans mon sac je pense
bien que si vous avez montré si j'avais
dit la vérité adriano avant qu'ils aient
vu le coût aurait été trop pénible j'ai
pensé que c'était plus délicat reste
très délicat isabelle là je vous
remercie de cette attention
et quand isabella viens de vous dire
voilà mon mari vous avez trouvé ça plus
agréable que si vous aviez vu son
alliance agréable je ne sais pas le coup
a été rude
il me semble que devant vous j'ai été
obligé de le croire c'était plus
évidente sans vous j'aurais douter même
en y voyant une alliance à une alliance
est moins évidente
un mari
ea cher monsieur je suis désolé de vous
imposer mon évidence mais je suis le
mari d'isabelle allez vous asseoir
merci alors en somme vous ne saviez rien
j'ai eu l'honneur
je ne peux donc pas vous en vouloir et
moi non plus je ne savais absolument
patrice abeille live vous mets toi toi
tu sais pourquoi
avec marco bien non
ça c'est le comble je le dis rien je ne
parle de rien et on engueule et c'est
moi la coupable
jaloux comme toi tu ne peux rien dire
sans qu'ils soient trompés qui vous
espionne tu m'avais en toi challans
experts d'avoir trois habitude j'étais
ici a commencé avec lui c'est une
méthode paraît commet parfois et c'est
moi la coupable et c'est à moi qu'on
pose des questions mais je veux vivre ma
conscience moi je crois qu'on pense
paraît qu'on espionne pas à dieu je m'en
vais je vous laisse ça vous apprendra
c'est ça s'il est petit on à l'elysée
[Applaudissements]
elle n'est pas contente
non elle à tempérament assez vifs mais
vous devriez la suite il faudra vous
voyez j'ai pas l'habitude de ce genre de
situation vous craignez vraiment que je
ne pense pas vous ne craignez pas un
malheur non franchement c'est exclue
d'après vous allez sûrement
alors j'ai mieux rester ici est énervée
elle dira encore que je l'espère comme
vous la connaissez suffisamment pour
considérer qu'un malheur est exclu c'est
à dire qu'en fait je ne vois pas quelles
raisons sérieuses et leurs rêves oui
n'est ce pas en fin de compte il ya il
n'y a pas de quoi fouetter un chat dans
tout ça parce que mon avis vous prenez
quelque chose no mercy je ne peux pas
dire que j'ai soif voulez oui en fait
tout se ramène à ceux ci nous avons sur
vous et moi chacun une époque différente
touché le coeur d'isabela et de nous
deux il se trouve que c'est moi qui
je n'ai aucune raison vous en vouloir
vous avez eu un amour malheureux voilà
oui pourquoi
pourquoi beaucoup vous la connaissez
depuis longtemps quoi pourquoi depuis
quand la connaissez vous un peu plus de
deux ans vous êtes parti en voyage à
quelle époque un peu moins de deux ans
c'est-à-dire il ya trois mois environ
pour l'amérique par bateau je vais
toujours en amérique par bateau c'est
moins dangereux
et puis c'est plus long il pendant votre
voyage vous n'avez échanger avec elles
aucune correspondance aucune puisque
vous vouliez l'oublier ça va aller mieux
je les crues
vous ne l'avez pas oublier non mais elle
vous oublier justement c'est ce que je
me demande où lui demander à mais moi je
vous le dis elle vous a oubliées
puisqu'elles mal cousine elle vous a
épousé mais elle ne m'a peut-être pas
oublié
hélas elle
alors le pied sur un terrain dangereux
je puis vous dire avec un certain nombre
de raisons pour le croire que d'isabella
n'a pas épousé par des haies en
admettant qu'elle l'ait fait j'ai des
raisons encore plus personnel de vous
dire que se dépêcher elle a disparu et
qu'il a même fait place à une certaine
ardeur amoureuse qui ne trompent pas
vous voulez dire que dans mes bras
isabelle là ne pense pas quelqu'un
d'autre ça je vous le garantis au jeu
vous demande pardon si j'ai manqué de
délicatesse au nom si si si et quand
elles étant donné votre situation
d'avant malheureuse mais je veux dire de
défiance et mais à ce propos puis-je me
permettent de vous poser une question
indiscrète dans un bruit avez vous
seulement étaient fiancés
que voulez vous je vais dire fiancé ou
autre chose ou allemand oui
qu'appelez-vous être à manger mieux si
l'amour enfin ce que j'appelle ce
sentiment très intense exclusif existe
entre deux êtres nous attendre à dire
que ces deux êtres sont amants oui
d'accord rue tristan et iseult par
exemple après avoir vu le film
etait-il des amants non à votre avis oui
tristan et isolde je n'étais pas là
vous vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas vu
le filtre c'est peut-être ce qui vous
trompe
vous aimez les métaphores compte et moi
ce que je voudrais savoir c'est une
chose précise isabelle lives nous avons
jusque-là convenu d'appeler des
relations intimes voilà si elle a été
votre maîtresse délais autant qu'on peut
l'être
en ce moment elle règne sur mon coeur
j'appelle cela être une maîtresse
oui bon ça j'ai compris mais si vous
avez couché ensemble
puisqu'il faut le dire oui ou non je
crois pouvoir vous assurer que non vous
n'êtes pas sûr si je mens je n'étais pas
comme vous des compartiments en amour
cher monsieur aimons et isabella comme
je les aimais mais il me semble que je
les possédés souffre oui mais ils vous
sans cela n'a pas été ou non jamais
c'est un poil actif vous pouvez en être
certain alors ça qu'est-ce qui va elle
n'a pas été votre maîtresse c'est ça qui
compte
vous voulez dire que tout ce qui peut
lier un homme et une femme née en dehors
du détail la auquel vous pensez on ne
compte pas je peux enfin ses invités y
mettait tout de même pas l'essentiel
c'était moi mais l'essentiel et c'est là
c'est la la la palpitation et voilà
voilà voilà le mot le terme juste la
palpitation particulière à deux êtres
qui fait que le bonheur existe ou pas
que ces deux êtres sont liés qu'ils ne
peuvent se passer l'un de l'autre qui
offre une conception bien primaire et
vient grossir de l'amour enfermés
témoigne d une super jeune aristocrate
mais on sort on estimer en somme que
pour avoir respecté isabelle là je suis
un rêve pour elle un rêve qui n'a pas
pris corps en quelque sorte et que notre
amour n'est qu'un mirage que vous seul
comptait pas ce coup là et nulle adam
bomb a et bien je ne vous laisserai pas
vous pavaner dans cette seule certitude
de vous mais je voulais voir jusqu'où
vous pouviez aller dans la valley telle
aveuglement mais maintenant votre
personnage de mary enflé de suffisance
imbécile je vais le crever comme une
baudruche
elle n'a pas été ma maîtresse non mais
c'est moi j'allais car elle vous a menti
je n'ai pas revu ici aujourd'hui pour la
première fois car je ne suis jamais allé
en amérique depuis votre mariage
je n'ai revu tous les jours tous les
jours nous étions à venise à venise ce
nombre est en voyage de noces nous
sommes rentrés ya dix jours à venise ne
deviez pas à syracuse et pourquoi si
rapide une seconde et deux secondes les
séparant les esprits il me vient quand
vous êtes vous mariée
le 23 avril le 23 avril mais ça me dit
quelque chose vous savez 23 avril
l'anniversaire de benyamin ou et c'est
ce jour là j'ai reçu des cartes postales
de syracuse pendant tout le temps de
votre voyage de noces eh bien il m'a
roulé nous avons été roulés tous les
deux l'escale plus fort que toi
qu'est-ce qui est encore à prendre au
nom asseyons nous asseyons nous
reprenons tout ça va trop loin ça va
trop loin du bon dieu vite que je les
assommer tout les 2è et la vieille
cher monsieur je vous demande mille fois
pardon pour le mouvement de colère que
julien lavoie et au cours duquel je vous
ai dit des choses insultant je vous fais
mes excuses
vous êtes un esprit aussi supérieur ou
mois et nous sommes deux imbéciles nous
n'avons plus rien à nous envier à un
autre nous n'avons plus qu'une chose à
faire nous unir faire front commun
contre une coquille une copine qui nous
a joué vous et moi comme deux gamins
elle vous a épousé +23 trois bons et
bien quelques jours avant ici veine avec
sa mère
avec sa mère elle me jouer la comédie
d'un départ prochain pour convalescence
à syracuse les annonces comédiens
comédiens tout avec elle et comédie mais
quelle oncle comme elle n'a pas donc la
syracuse min à syracuse new year and now
qu'elle nous est allé dont elle n'a plus
donc à chaque plat on met le pied dans
une crevasse
donc elle m'a caché votre mariage
elle m'a trompée comme aucun homme ne
peut être enviés par une femme est à
vous elle a caché mon existence et
l'amour qui nous unissait c'est le
mensonge incarné dans une femme hèle
elia mais savez vous ce qui est plus
grave non et les comptages
voilà ce que j'ai l'air de les couvrir
car je m'aperçois que le pi l'instant
vous êtes entré dans ce café depuis
l'instant vous êtes apparu à la porte je
vous ai menti
d'abord avec elle on accord tacite avec
elle et puis tout seul à 300 départs
je vous ai menti tout le temps mais
alors vous avez couché avec elle mais
non mais c'est la seule chose dont je
vous ai dit vous avez si je vous donne
ma parole de gentilles alors ça
je ne suis jamais allé en amérique je
n'ai jamais rompu ce que j'appelais le
fiançailles ben oui c'est moi qui étais
défend d'exploiter à votre école pour
vous dire que votre femme stati six ans
c'est vous oui et je peux je vais la
prendre votre mariage j'ai voulu la
mettre au pied du mur la forcer à avouer
j'ai voulu voir le visage qu'elle aurait
devant nous deux est belle elle est
devenue verte
vous visiez carrément vous êtes
entraînement a enfoncé ses ongles dans
la main tellement l'a eu peur teulet on
en voit encore les traces et à il a bien
fallu quelque part oui et pour une fois
l'a dit la vérité à moi pas à vous le
mensonge a commencé tout de suite quand
elle vous a dit que je revenais de
voyage
il avait ajouté qu'il débarquait
d'emeric pour connaître pourquoi c'est
ce que je dis pourquoi moi j'avais
organisé cette rencontre pour l'appelant
fondé pour la juger elle fait de moi son
complice en une seconde est contre vous
je mentais auto lequel est aussi bien
libre et plus je me sentais vous mentir
plus je m'amusais à bout physiquement
trop longtemps que je pouvais le thé le
marié classique idéal à qui on raconte
n'importe quoi c'est une pression
irrésistible avait continué pendant que
vous y êtes
anonyme je vous dis de quoi elle est
capable elle passerait menti moi
humainement savez chaque cas ça ne se
passera pas comme ça et s'est échappé
mais j'ai retrouvé ici son mari dans
cette histoire elle va s'en apercevoir
je vais lui apprendre alors si vous n'en
croyez la violence ne sert à rien nous
la tenons et ne peut plus rien contre
nous si nous nous unissons oui mais
c'est à moi à vous de votre côté à moi
du mien
elle nous a roulé roulant à notre tour
alors voilà nous allons nous voir tous
les jours si vous louez bien nous
reconstitueront d'abord tous ces
mensonges rouge
comment un s'est servi d'eux l'un contre
l'autre et vice versa mais nous mettrons
au point notre vengeance nous la verrons
à nos genoux il faudra bien qu'elle
demande grâce et quelle façon sera un
geste qui nous prouvera à tous les deux
sa sincérité
jusque-là occupants de notre plan alors
à votre avis du cas pas pour le moment
c'est ce qui peut inquiéter le plus de
votre côté du gave du mépris et du bien
une souveraine indifférence elle
deviendra enragé et nous lui ferons
fermer un culte à la
d'accord du calme c'est l'auteur
cher monsieur
au revoir alors à demain ici 11h30
d'accord c'est mon heure de sortie de
classe
naturellement secret absolu sur tout ce
que je vous ai dit quand tu es sur
mouche du calme et locales d'accord mais
moi je vais commencer par te lèves et
depuis six jours que ce port ethernet et
sûrement avec l'autre et qu'ils se sont
mis d'accord tous les deux contre toi tu
ne dis rien tu laisses faire
je voudrais bien savoir quel est le
[ __ ] qu'étaient les prévenir avec
vidéo je le connais celui là abel
individus en tout cas s'ils jouent ça
pue cinq nuits et bien moi je ne le
supporterais pas que mon mari me méprise
pendant cinq nuits et couchent dans la
pièce à côté
non ça c'est une honte tu ne devrais pas
supporté si tu te comprends pas ça tu
n'es plus une femme dit l'on écoute tu
continues à ne rien lui dire c'est moi
qui va venir ici une nuit ils ne sortent
s'arrête sur l'idée qu'il jetterait dans
le tien qu'il avait eu là n'avait plus
de principe
les jeunes et l'autre là ton compte
il ne remplit bouche par tu penses il
téléphone + calvino ils s'entendent
comme deux larrons et sur ton dos fière
de moi j'ai surtout dit j'ai surpris des
conversations avec adriano aloïs albino
ryan
jérôme attal guinot disait je suis nous
sommes forts nous sommes très forts
elles reprennent au genou du vérin et en
bus depuis avant-hier ils se tutoient
voilà vous ils se tutoient il se paie la
tête alors tu va les laisser faire
encore longtemps dit bien entendu albino
dire nous sommes très forts oui et aussi
elles reprennent au genou mais ça ne
fait rien oui ça me fait rêver ça me
fait rire et à partir de maintenant tu
vas riom aussi j'ai bien pensé le
premier jour en retrouvant albino qu'ils
allaient combiner quelque chose tous les
deux et si depuis six jours je me dis
rien c'est que j'avais besoin d'en
savoir davantage ils sont très forts
je vais ramper à leurs genoux eh bien
ils vont voir ils vont voir si deux
hommes ni contre une femme sont plus
fort qu'elle quand cette femme c'est
mentir dans les 24 heures
je vais les reprendre tous les deux par
le mensonge je vais les séparer et les
reprendre là après l'autre
et quand les aurait repris je les verrai
ici même à mais je mouille en pleurant
ils me demanderont pardon pardon pardon
à mes intentions
albino a été tu ne sera pas facile avec
tous mes filles toile albino mais c'est
lui que je vais reprendre le premier
aujourd'hui même ce soir il a rendez
vous avec adriano a nommé comme tous les
soirs à 9 heures il sera dans mon lit
mais sûr je suis même sûr qu'ils n'en
sortira pas avant demain matin
et là j reccueillir adriano chez lui et
il fera ce que je voudrais demain matin
dès demain matin
bon maintenant à guilo va rentrer alors
tu vas nous laisser seuls dix minutes
pas plus afin pourquoi tu reviendras ce
moment là sans faute d'accord mais
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi parce que si
tu ne rentres pas il va vouloir passer
dans la chambre avant le dîner moi c'est
après que je veux le coincer et pour
qu'ils aillent pas retrouvé adrian aussi
dix minutes un pas plus la paix si
c'était pas moi qui rentrait c'est comme
ça que tu recevras le visiteur visiteurs
qu'elle visite à l visiteurs là oui quel
visiteur
tu vois souvent des visites et aussi à
7h30 et tu connais beaucoup de visiteurs
qui entrent chez les gens avec la clé de
leur appartement
c'est pas une tenue pour recevoir les
gens aux europe à personne c'est toi qui
y entre sans vous avez là mais je
reviens jamais pour dix minutes pas plus
tusa nuit dix minutes ma chérie pas plus
dix minutes pas plus on est votre temps
pourquoi es tu auras tes chansons ça ça
te gêne aussi je m'habille comment veux
tu que je sois tu t'habilles pourquoi
sortir par ben le corps ce soir puisque
toi tu sors de ton côté
où vas-tu pas au vieil empire assure toi
et avec qui
par adrian se doit le savoir puisque tu
seras avec lui alors avec qui j'ai bien
droit d'aller au cinéma tout seul non
puisque toi tu préfères retrouver à
briane pour quoi faire au cinéma puis
quoi encore on est en afrique ici tu es
devenu sultan j'ai plus droit d'aller au
cinéma sans sa permission spéciale
essentiel d'adriano peut-être il va
falloir que tu me rendais compte que tu
lui explique que j'ai au cinéma
rabastens laisse moi tranquille avec
adrian bientôt aussi laisse pas
tranquille avec lui tu crois que j'ai
pas remarqué depuis six jours que tu est
entre ses mains
- que faire tout ce qu'il veut du
contraire non mais tu t'entraînes tu en
arrives à ma première offusqué parce que
j'enfile mes bas devant toi ça te va
bien ça tient un mot pour albino depuis
six jours
tu te revient de parler
tu vis comme un homme car ce une
consigne tu m'as un point d'honneur à
coucher là tout seul sur des canapés du
fait pitié puis aussi un petit peu de
peine je ne passe de tels pics et figure
pendant ces six jours j'acceptais ton
silence était boudry parce que je
voulais que tu comprennes tout seul une
petite lueur se fasse dans ton cerveau
qui remettraient les choses en place
mais tu n'as toujours pas compris alors
maintenant c'est moi qui vais parler
savent bien qu adriana ne le fera jamais
ils avaient bien trop peur lors de quoi
cathy soupçonne la vérité c sté énigmes
si tu veux bien qu est-ce que je pouvait
soupçonner
est-ce qu adriano a parlé de
l'annulation de son mariage
quel mariage comme il est marié
je ne savais même pas qu'il était marié
j'ai mélangé de quoi vous parlez alors
que les deux petits jours
mais comme il avait même caché ça c'est
pas possible quoique il est marié à baie
saint jean c'est quelque chose que ma
confiance
mais alors vous fiançailles ne voulait
rien dire on n'est pas fier ancien homme
marié il est étonnamment m'a menti il
est étonnamment justement c'est là que
je vais en il a été ton amant il ya bien
je vais t'expliquer tu vas comprendre à
mon amant lui il a été marié trois mois
ou plutôt au bout de trois mois
sa femme et lui se sont séparés et pour
m'épouser il voulait demander
l'annulation de son mariage et ils
pouvaient obtenir cette annulation
c'est pourquoi pourquoi pour une des
raisons principales à tous permettent de
l'obtenir en fa si la femme est d'accord
il ya encore ça alors quelle région
mariages blancs mariage blanc mais oui
ça pourquoi sa femme laure et elle
quitté au bout de trois mois
mais pourquoi un mariage permet pourquoi
réfléchit pas pourquoi
pourquoi n'as tu jamais été mon amant
car ne lis pas je l' ai connues plus
d'un an avant toi pour la même raison
ça arrive souvent dans les grandes
familles
art
il est impuissant tu veux dire
adrien non il est le pauvre à aa
alors j'espère j'espère maintenant que
tu comprends tout 1 d'abord pourquoi
j'ai rompu nos fiançailles à quand j'ai
su la vérité
et puis surtout pourquoi je ne t'ai
jamais parler plus ils même comme un
collégien
je sais qu'avec lui je ne risquais pas
absolument rien aucun danger d'aucune
sorte d'attachement répète un collégien
que ça pouvait le faire à toi un cas
d'hommes comme lui soit mais jubin et si
je ne lui ai jamais parlé de mariage
c'est que je savais quel drame affreux
ce serait pour lui pour moi ça ne change
rien mais pour lui savoir que savoir que
j'allais appartenir à un homme un vrai
tu t'imagines l'humiliation la
souffrance mais ça représentait le pool
savoir qu'à notre allée faire avec moi
ce que toi et que lui
et les hommes comme lui sont des
passionnés tu sais comme ils sont
incapables de prendre une femme leurs
sentiments sont d'une violence
extraordinaire et jamy com est le pou
lui avait d'ailleurs d'ailleurs tu n'as
qu'à voir sa réassurance ait eu une
telle manoeuvre est tout de suite dans
le sens me voulait et toi bien sûr on tu
ne savais pas comment ça j'ai plongé
qu'est ce que j'ai fait ce qu'il voulait
chambre à part vous n'etes pas pu
coucher avec moi ça me rend fou pensez à
ça aulas va je le connais tu sais je le
connais mais qu'est ce que tu veux on
peut pas d'envolées en vouloir on
nettoie sa place à ben oui bien sûr
pourvus alors c'est moi qui connaissait
la vérité tu rejoues commencé quand même
à trouver que la plaisanterie dure est
un peu long tabac oui là maintenant je
suis d'accord avec toi alors que non et
que vous voyez tous les jours parfois ça
je trouve ça même très bien il faut donc
que vous soyez devenus de vrais amis
j'attends c'est parfait tout ça mais qui
t'oblige à coucher tout cela sur un
canapé contre un texte qu'elle est
impuissant parra alors là tu vois là je
trouve qu'il allait quand même un peu
loin
sa créatrice ils ont des trucks
aygalades et toi moi je commençais pas à
trouver les nuits un peu long à jabel
[Musique]
j'ai bien fait de tout dire non toi
aussi tu dors plus je suis une femme
noire aux rites une femme et ce soit non
non ce soir
non comme quoi mais tu es folle comment
fais-tu a rendez vous avec lui moi je
vais au cinéma tatatata finira par le
cinéma couchera pour fat ans jamais je
me couche
c'est avec toi sans cela pas question
m'ennuie tout son talent à côté n'aura
qu'à lui dire que tu le verras
demain je veux maintenant après ton tour
tu crois que je peux l'appeler ce soir
là je ne sais pas si c'est à toi d
c'est à toi toi doit réfléchir ce soir
qu'est ce que tu préfères lui ou moi
dans un peu les squats
je vais arranger ça
[Musique]
diallo à lviv salle où tu es bien via
mais j'ai un petit pépin je pourrais pas
te rejoindre à 9 heures non à un
collègue qui m'a remis son paquet de
composition a corrigé à sa place
pourquoi parce qu'il a perdu sa belle
mère
et pour demain matin 8 heures mais si tu
veux entendre ce soir à 20h30 au café un
bien très bien
dac et oui je vous dis ce sont les
petits a prévu des métiers tiendrions le
pot mur quand je pense à vous vous
pouvez dire nous avait épousé une femme
une vraie les caisses qu'elle ne veut
encore celles ci on est à 10 heures tout
va bien comment mais monsieur le comte
va chercher son excellence l'ambassadeur
d'angleterre et bien neuf et demi
oui car l'eau étant avec la peinture
votre ami âgé des soins dans cinq
minutes
j'ai quelques documents à signer afin de
répondre à louis ii madame ne quittez
pas madame je vais voir ce monsieur le
comte est encore là qu'est ce que c'est
que nous sommes fous gliales oui enfin
je vais quand même
allô allô isabelle l'homme et ben oui
c'est moi mais oui mais oui je t'entends
oui oui j'allais sortir j'ai une
réception et 10,1 mais avant je dois
aller chercher l'ambassadeur de grande
bretagne
oui d'angleterre bis b oui c'est pareil
mais quelle drôle de voiture tu as de la
fièvre quelques l g
il est arrivé un drame il peut-on
arriver
qu'est ce que mes dix mois mais mais où
es tu en ce moment dans le petit café en
bas de chez moi
tu tu veux monter annonce isabelle à ce
n'est pas possible c'est une peu non il
avait l'air je t'assure bons ballons
statut remonte tout de suite elle même
c'est pas ce qui se passe mais à sa voix
un peu rauque eux j'ai compris qu'elle
même et qu'elle est à bout j'y gagne
albino ne reprochera jamais plus et
c'est moi qu'elle a la diplomatie sa
diplomatie et surtout avec les femmes
que ce mot-là veut dire quelque chose
mais attention
continuant à être diplomate de toute
façon j'ai gagne chaque année
adrian on sait que tvo
alors là tu achètes un bras tu
m'impressionnes tu as l'air d'un
portrait oui bon alors oui j'ai une
réception à 10 heures oui tu me l'a dit
alors que se passe-t-il
tu la demande évidemment je te demandais
vraiment petit jeu fait attendre
l'ambassadeur d'angleterre l'ambassadeur
d'angleterre c'est donc que tueur est un
petit peu envie me voir tu es donc c'est
est urgent qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
attendre c'est exact cette valise
t'explique pourquoi cette valise
la dernière chose que tu médites adrian
c'est de faire un jour un geste de
prouverait massa réalité ce geste je le
fais adriano je pars je pars avec toi ou
tu voudras moi tu vois je suis déjà
parti
tu es parti de chez toi oui mais tu
voles pourquoi mais parce que perdre si
tu es folle et albino en reste et albino
mutuelle ou moi c'est entendu mais c'est
quoi
mais je ne peux pas partir comme ça à
moins de but en blanc tu vois j'ai mon
service au vatican
quand je dis partir je veux dire que je
suis parti de chez moi et que je suis à
toi enfin nous pouvons rester à rome
si tu préfères annonce hervé pourquoi
benoît et moi nous sommes devenus de
vrais amis
mais ce qui aurait été possible
autrefois hypocrite quoi tu te mords
bien d'albino pas du tout ne me prends
pas pour une dinde tu vas demander un
geste oui ou non ce geste je le fais
nous le sait plus c'est pas possible tu
es heureux je ne peux pas l'accepter
ce geste c'est toi qui ne le fera jamais
adriano qui n'aurait jamais fait
tu es de ceux qui rêvent d'annuler mais
qui n'annule pas de ceux qui rêvent de
partir mais tu ne partent jamais adrian
c'est pourquoi nous voilà qu'est ce que
ça veut dire les vides ça veut dire que
je connaissais la réponse est que cette
valise n'avait pas besoin d'être pleine
alors maintenant c'est son votre petit
jeu de cache-cache tu veux je t'aime et
tu m'aimes et nous avons assez perdu de
temps que cela ne parlons pas de partir
et de faire notre vie ensemble je ne
suis pas fait pour être conteste je le
sais aussi bien que toi est-ce que tu ne
sais pas adriano tu n'as pas l'air de
savoir si je suis une femme une vraie et
que je n'ai plus qu'à désir c'était de
le faire découvrir et de me sentir dans
tes bras pour la première fois pour la
première fois tout me paraît clair entre
nous
je suis dans le décor sérieux de ta
bibliothèque et pourtant pour la
première fois je me sens chez moi et
tout à fait à l'aise pour la première
fois je me sens nu devant toi je t'en
prie javel c'est vrai c'est vrai tout ce
qu'il veut c'est paris a brusquement
disparu il me semble que je viens de
passer la nuit avec toi que tu m'as
rendu très heureuse et que je circule
toutes nues quand ton appartement
entendra sans de temps en temps embrasse
moi tu es aussi leurs coûts et doutent
franchement ce n'est pas le moment
pourquoi est-ce que je suis une nuée de
caméras et du pardon que deux tu adores
d'importuner pas nul mais si je te dis
complètement nu sa jane on n'était pas
en cardinal quand même
ah bah oui je comprends c'est ta fraise
qui t'empêche ça je dois dire que c'est
aussi un cobot que possible à des actes
et grands avec ta fret et devient
inabordable que me tuer moi je ne peux
pas aller tout nu au vatican on n'y va
pas quoi restons là pour la première
fois nous sommes chez toi pas dans un
café nous sommes chez nous tous les deux
seuls ferme les rideaux
adriano reste là tu plaisantes eu sa
mère mais non mais alors tu es folle qui
n'a pas envie de moi pendant mon
grand-père enfin et avec toutes mes
décorations bonté décoration est en fait
déjà en émoi tout il est 9h45 je ne peux
pas avoir envie de moi à 10 heures du
matin un homme ce n'est pas steve et le
corps diplomatique maintenant un site
important c'est de savoir si on a envie
de moi ou non non écouter à ses toiles à
jour devient bon tu vois là bon jeu
massy
c'est là tout cas pas maintenant que tu
es pas mon niveau
regarde moi
[Musique]
bon
il appelle à la chair est faible où tu
sais où tu me plais tu as un goût de
fraise
tu devras suis je suis nulle part toi et
moi ne me tuent plus que tu vas y eut
d'abord ces troubles oui enfin non enfin
je trouve ça plus il a dit oui tu as dit
oui je suis nue devant toi tu as envie
de moi non je ne veux pas avoir envie de
moi si tu veux mais si je peux annoncer
à lui parce que je dis je je ne peux pas
maintenant quoi
eh bien tu le vois ma fraise mon costume
bien on lève le ton costume je peux
parler d'une seule pièce le plaisir non
plus tu crois que je plaisante
alors raison donc c'est non tu ne veux
pas alors c'est us que je commence à me
demander
adriano l'idée m'en étais venu souvent
mais maintenant je crois que je vais en
être sûr sûr de quoi
mais si ton mariage a été un mariage
blanc c'est à cause de toi tu pensais
que je que je suis que je ne
on voit contraire tu le pense vraiment
mais mais mais mais mais c'est faux
sanaa était vrai qu'avec paula pourquoi
mais pourquoi je t'ai pas peut-être
parce que nous étions mon cousin
oui et que nous jouions enfants quand
nous étions petits enfants non j'ai déjà
pu être son amant c'est vrai mais je le
jure que j'ai eu d'autres femmes dans ma
vie sains et qu'avec celle là
ah bon avant ce qui veut dire que depuis
deux ans moi je suis c'est la tient à
qui on tient la main dans un cas c'est
mais qu'il y en a d'autres avec écoute
moi bien adriano cet après midi je serai
ici à 5h à 7h à toi enlevé d'or cap est
cet après midi tu n'es pas mon amant
adriano je saurai que tu es impuissant
et je le dirai albino mais c'est faux on
lui dirait quand même et si toi tu lui
assuré le contraire c'est quand même moi
qui croire et carnot contraire et pense
à lui que tu pourrais le prouver
[Musique]
rendez vous avec monsieur quand un homme
charmant un vrai gentilhomme les
longtemps que le connaissez oh je disais
justement l'autre jour à la terre enfin
et je veux dire indom une dame qui me
posa la question at il vient souvent ici
avec des dames blanches
enfin je veux dire que quelquefois mais
voyez-vous monsieur et je ne suis pas
trés trés physionomiste non
et puis ma vue baisse beaucoup depuis
quelques temps alors les dames
je ne sais jamais si c'est la même ou si
elles sont plusieurs c'est vrai les
visages diderot n'est ce pas les visages
je ne les retient pas tu les retient pas
du tout ceux des dames je veux dire et
puis de nos jours les dames se
ressemblent beaucoup
la même coiffure souvent il ya longtemps
que vous êtes ici inodore
ça a été ma deuxième place monsieur qui
a fait 51 morts cette année 51 ans vous
avez dû en voir alors des dames c'est ce
que j'ai à monsieur jean des temps vous
que surtout l'après midi pour que
l'après midi eh bien monsieur parce que
le matin les fans sont occupés par leur
ménage
le soir elles sont avec leurs marges
alors c'est surtout l'après midi que je
les vois ici
vous voulez dire que l'après midi les
femmes maria ne viennent pas ici avec
leur mari oui
qu'est-ce que je servirai monsieur avec
ça avec ça je prendrai un verre de
lacryma christi par faible je vais pas
penser à l'après midi mois
faudra-il occuper l'après midi et
l'occupé sans risque mais avec qui au
port vieux
[Musique]
salut alpil de van houtte et à dia
[Rires]
comment vas tu eh ben j'ai chaud ces
jeux je sors de cette réception au
vatican dont je t'avais part et où la
poussette uniforme d'une seule pièce
avec la fraise l'épée en crète dans sa
ne pas être bien pratique
pratique oui enfin on doit pas être à
l'aise
pas spécialement il a fallu que je
rentre vite me changer je ne vais pas te
faire attendre non j'arrivais juste j'ai
commandé un verre de lacryma christi
parfait dans les apporter 2 ap
merci riri d'isidore au chili
ses compositions quelle composition et
bien tes copines hier soir ah oui c'est
vrai auger était désolé oh non c'est
surtout un lieu pour toi ça peut être
très long le rentrer chez soi de se
mette à corriger des copies et si vous
mettiez et oui mon vieux tu t'es coucher
tu as tu as laissé ses longs de corriger
une composition
ça dépend des cas souvent jusque vers
minuit au mieux quelques forces on n'est
pas remarqué des élèves qui ont des
idées amusantes la wii en fait toute
façon pendant ce temps-là tu ne dors pas
et le lendemain matin tu es fatigué
pourquoi j'ai l'air fatigué toi non tu
as l'air d'aller très bien a bon est ce
que c'est vrai tu va très bien
oui alors c'est pas tout ça
quelle nouvelle isabelle statut coup
droit toujours le mépris total fin du
mois elle n'ose plus m'adresser la
parole elle s'enferre dans le silence
bravo et ben moi figure toi qu'elle m'a
téléphoné non ce matin m
tu as répondu non j'ai pris l'appareil
et quand j'ai reconnu sa voix j'ai
seulement dit je ne suis pas là tu
raccroches et tu es dur avec les femmes
c'est comme ça qu'on les tire et toi tu
me touche moi pas tu penses tu vois
annonce plus de parler à la santissima
je crois oui ya aussi cette impression
de plus en plus si c'est non je te
plains m'a dit où je pensais la façon
dont tu as répondu au téléphone je crois
que dès maintenant en fait nous avons
gagné la partie
mais il me sentais les clous et nous a
dit après dira les clous j'allais avec
nous
hier soir elle a touché les épaules en
ce1 à une boisson
alors je me demande s'il ne devrions pas
montré une certaine manière limitée
c'est à dire par un fusil de notre force
notre victoire nous risquerions de
l'amener peut-être on ne sait pas à
quelques gestes qui renversa la
situation nous perdrions tout à coup la
face aux travaux mais je comprend une
femme c'est une femme tue qu'on prenne
sur lui refait serti certaine
satisfaction elle peut devenir folle
et alors toi tu serais d'avis de
reprendre la conversation a seulement la
conversation
moi de mon côté je l'a puni je continue
à la punit jeffrey chambre à part
peut-être encore six mois
ils manquent pas d'autres femmes pour
moi si je bain mais pour supporter ça il
faut qu'elle ait autre chose qu il
occupait le sentiment par exemple pour
les femmes ça prend beaucoup elles
peuvent vivre avec le sentiment là la
palpitation de l'âme palpitations c'est
moi qui avais employés de cette image de
marque je sais ce que tu m'as dit le
premier jour qui a justement entre vous
une sorte de sentiment
il y avait oui mais en conservant cette
attitude intransigeante au fond tu te
prives d'un grand plaisir pur fait
violence a il est certain et de contenu
de son côté que représente pour elle une
sorte d'amusement l'amusement de
distraction [ __ ] je ne sais pas si le
terme est encore fragile ce qui condense
musulmane ont si tu peux appeler les
choses par leur nom ce qui existe entre
elle et moi représente tout à fait autre
chose que de distraction et encore moins
un amusement
je ne te laisse jamais caché c'est un
amour oui oui on peut aussi à nous on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas il faut il faut
il n'y a pas d'autres où il a justement
cet amour représente ce sentiment dont
je te parle et qui pourrait être en
quelque sorte une compensation kareo
c'est peut-être aussi joué avec le feu
ce qu'elle fout le feu de l'amour bornes
oui mais avec toi je suis tranquille 1
je veux dire que je sais que ce qui
compte c'est le sentiment la force du
sentiment
maintenant que nous sommes deux amis je
sais aussi que tu es un homme d'honneur
de scrupules et que jamais jamais qu'il
ne touchera isabelle dois jouer je ne
pose même pas ça comme un conditions je
te fais confiance avec une nature comme
la tienne
je sais que tu ne voudrais tu pourrais
okada tu sais que tu me flatte beaucoup
même si je sais que ce n'est pas qu'ils
en soient capables tu vois et bien je
prends lorsque les yeux fermés et je te
le dis je suis tranquille
en somme c'est toi qui me demandent de
la revoir
tu estimes que sans déchoir nous
pourrions reprendre la conversation
seulement la tendance étant bien entendu
que toi de ton côté tu garderas ça s'est
réglé une fois pour toutes de ce point
de vue là le transistor et moi je
pourrais leur voir ou à revoir cet après
midi mais quand il veut l'après-midi moi
je suis en classe tous les jours jusqu'à
7 heures
plus tu la vois mieux ça vous tue
l'occupent pas dû être sûr d'être libre
parce que mon point de vue est celui ci
le jour où par des piles désoeuvrement
elle s'intéresserait à notre homme celui
qui serait caucus ce serait moi et pas
toi le mari c'est moi tout changer à
tout moment avec toi je suis paré pop
dont j'ai aucun effet sur le toit je
crois que tu as région avignon il faut
rétablir le dialogue nous falloir être
amenés aujourd'hui même tu ne seras pas
jaloux mais pas du tout non je me dis
cet amour tu admet qu'il existe entre
elle et moi à mes parts bleus le
sentiment ça ne se commande pas je sais
que pour toi c'est ce qui compte le plus
tu les as a passionné 1 sentimentale les
femmes adorent ça du moment que pour le
reste je peux compter sur toi et si un
jour je te trahir
je te le dis adriano je prends le bus
alors ça va je ne serai plus tu reprends
la conversation nous la reprenons
les rebelles
[Musique]
quoi qu'est ce que tu as fait qu'est ce
que tu a avalé une infinitude a dans le
lait les conquois zon études et
j'emploie ce n'est le sommer je me
remets avant je voulais que vous ne
demandiez part dans tous les deux en 140
ans il s'appelle nous appelle là pardon
comme toi c'est pas le moment
comment mais un rappeur comme en mêlée
alors tu t'es pas empoisonner - dépend
dans quel état vous seriez si j'avais
fait mais alors pourquoi cette nouvelle
comédie parce que je voulais vous avoir
tous les deux à mes côtés et que vous
vous rendiez compte tous les deux de
votre amour et aussi parce que j'en ai
assez de vos mensonges vous êtes de
mental ou non c'est toi il me semble
albino est ce que tu veux dire adriano
qui hier nous étions nous avions
commencé à nous parler et que nous
admettions parler jusqu'à nous meilleur
soin de composition alors et twg adriano
est ce que tu as dit albino que ce matin
j'étais venu te voir chez toi ouah mais
tu m'avais dit que tu avais raccroché le
téléphone sont lus par les champions
c'est honteux loi qui avait confiance en
toi aussi jamais confiant le premier
jour d'ailleurs tu m'as manqué lundi
aujourd'hui tu m'as trahi d'une façon
abominable et bien maintenant j'ai bien
maintenant kwaï exactement à qui la
faute
non mais pas recommencer vous massez
assez de mal maintenant entre nos trois
je veux la vérité et je veux pouvoir
tout dit de dire quoi il ya par exemple
que la vie commencera aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même
cet après midi est bien mais dit le dit
le je suis d'accord a dit noter d'accord
que la vie commence pour nous trois cet
après midi oui je ne sais pas tellement
pourquoi tu tiens à cet après midi mais
je suis d'accord mais tu es heureux
et toi briano tu es d'accord que la vie
commence pour nous trois cet après midi
est tué jamais je n'aurais été davantage
si vous saviez ce que c'est bon
le dire une voie la vérité vraie et que
tout le monde soit content
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était la coquine de monsieur andré au
sein de l'académie française
jaffray la pièce de diego fabry la
bogart
nous devons nos décors à roger harth nos
costumes
à donald car weld
et la musique à michel france
cette coquine été joyeusement interprété
par jean pierre andré
[Musique]
henri courseaux
gisèle touraine
jean pierre barrier
max d'hérault
christiane muller
mario gamme
dans une mise en scène de bernard dhéran
[Musique]